why are women but it suited to calm the
men because we're used to faking it
what's the thing you've learned from
working with rebel Wilson oh that improv
is a god-given gift and some of it can
learn and we can improve but what she
has is truly a gift and we're just lucky
that we get to turn on the camera and
recorder to make us laugh again and
again because she just she pulls it out
of nowhere I've never I've it's really
something to witness and I just really
like that I got to see it up close she
can come up with a different insult like
15 takes in a row completely original
like side-splitting lee hilarious
insults right no I know you're a huge
fan of RuPaul's Drag Race if you had to
pick because I am too I share it with
you if you had to pick a one of the drag
race stars to be one of your con artist
buddies in the next movie who would it
be that is a really difficult question
because there's so many I would pick
just to hang out with you know shangela
shangela I think she's got a I don't
know I don't know I just trust shangela
I feel like all she does is just be and
be better and anyway there's so many
good things and so I'm not I'm sorry
shangela you deserve better you deserve
more articulation that I'm giving you
right now but I think I think shangela
would be great but I also I loved when
they exchanged you know because if we
got caught I trust Monet exchange to be
able to talk us out of it she can talk
about anything since I also think H
O'Hara would be amazing to be I don't
know if you read her Instagram captions
but they are works of art